- So can you tell me a time
that you showed leadership skills?
- Yes, of course.
In my previous job
I took the initiative to
expand our clientele to Asia.
Built my own biz devs sub-team
which allowed us to double
our revenue within six months.
- Great. That's awesome.
Now tell it again,
but in reverse.
- Wait, what? Why?
What does that have to do--
- You never reversed a story before?
I mean, it's a pretty
standard interview question.
- Yeah. I, I mean, I
I really don't understand
how that's related
to my job or how that's related
to the day to day work that I'd be doing.
All right, fuck it.
Okay.
Six months within revenue
doubled built my sub-team,
expanded clientele to Asia.
I took initiative.
- Great. Yeah.
Now say it again,
but more efficiently,
using only five words.
(intense music playing)
- Revenue, double, Asia, initiative.
The.
- Awesome. Yeah. No, that's a good start.
But do you think you can do better?
Do you think the way
you told your story was
the most optimal?
(intense music playing)
Can you do it without
saying a single word?
Ah, ah, ah.
Not a single word.
Think about your word efficiency.
(intense music playing)
- Great.
That's exactly what I was looking for.
You got it right!
But,
but,
you didn't really
explain your process and how
you came up with your answer.
So unfortunately, you won't be
proceeding to the next round.
Yeah. But, but, but
thanks for coming though
I really appreciate it.
- What the fuck?